now as I recall and I don't recall a lot
last year we met in your backyard is
that right that's right wonderful we had
a wonderful time I think Sona was a
little over served if I recall okay
because you make a powerful cocktail and
then Sona showed absolutely no
restraints that's very true and you know
what it's
going to be the same thing this time
what was the cocktail last year it was
spectacular it was called the chilled
Chum okay yeah and it was made of
chilled uh the the bits of fish that are
used to attract sharks I I yeah I
believe you said it looked like little
mouse Hearts yeah no it was actually
amazing it was great it was fantastic I
will I'm being perfectly honest with you
last year's drink was amazing and has a
lot to um this year's drink is going to
have a hard time this looks quite
different what is this this is called
the ginger Menace okay and these are
little Conan heads oh look at that it's
got the either that's a pompadour or a
tumor well it can be both
okay uh beautiful looking great
presentation Matt thank you yeah that's
really nice this is um bootleg Cuban rum
God aperol and ginger beer with a little
bit of fresh ginger and lemon and
there's also just because I know you
like dazzly drinks there's some edible
glitter in here oh that's fantastic yeah
that's I I mean I'm like Hemi way only I
demand glitter in my drinks but in every
other way thank you for making this
cheers this is look at that I like the
little Conan that you made out of
um looks like a sectioned grapefruit and
then here to test it is there some
on the ice cube yeah that's a little uh
cowboy
my grandpa had this little logo for his
company of a little cowboy and you can
get like little wax stamps made and you
just run it under water and press it
into the ice oh that's fantastic isn't
that stupid it's not stupid at all
I love it I love this promotion for
Yellowstone in my drink okay here we go
here's my first sip oh that's nice you
know what Matt you know I'm not a fan so
this I mean this with all honesty and
sincerity you make an amazing cocktail
well thank you this is really good I
mean it is not only aesthetically
pleasing but good Lord I knew you like
drum I love rum yeah and this is
communist rum so you know it's good I
love communist rum yeah I love it's the
people's rum yeah it's the rum
um we've brought down the the pigs
no but you put it in you put it in your
drink and I'm still I'm gonna drink this
drink soda it's not your fault it's a
little top heavy it is as am I yeah
um okay this is fantastic I do love a
rum drink and I just want to put it out
there if you ever see me at a bar and uh
you wanna
um strike the right note I love uh I
love me rum I'm part pirate in that way
I don't uh pillage I don't plunder and I
have no uh courage and
um well there's what makes you a pirate
the rum part okay I like to drink me rum
okay and then I like to fall asleep
listening to my own podcast
[Laughter]
which to me says pirate all the way